a brief glimmer of hope in an otherwise
terrible news cycle
republicans have successfully torpedoed
one of joe biden's most
radical nominees that would be nira
tandon
former head of center for american
progress who was up
to be the director of the office of
management and budget
uh senator rob portman republican
decided to read her her own record
in an explanation of why the senators
probably were not going to vote to
confirm her
you wrote that susan collins is quote
the worst
that ted tom cotton is a fraud
that vampires have more heart than ted
cruz
uh you called leader mcconnell moscow
mitch
and voldemort and on
and on i wonder specifically how do you
plan to amend fences and build
relationships with members of congress
you have attacked
through your public statements
senator uh i very much appreciate that
question
i recognize the concern i
deeply regret and apologize for my
language and
some of my past language um i recognize
that this role is a
bipartisan role and i know i have to
earn the trust of
senators across the board i deleted
tweets because
i regretted my tone and i've deleted
tweets over many months i
so but for those concerned about my my
rhetoric
and my language you know i i'm
i'm sorry and i'm sorry for any hurt
that they've caused
i bet she's regretting them now because
nero tandon has withdrawn
her nomination for omb finally
we get a little bit just a little bit to
halt
the radicalism of the biden
administration i'm michael moses the
michael knowles show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday's from
idahoman54 who says dr seuss's new book
is
oh the places you won't go because
you're canceled
that one's you know not quite as
uplifting as the original but
probably a fitting update for the times
that we are living in
tricky times means you got to be
prepared when you want to be prepared
you got to check out ready wise ready
wise is the leader in emergency food
supplies with a selection of emergency
meals freeze dried fruits and vegetables
for convenient on the go nutrition
and new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable
order online and have nutritious meals
shipped directly to your doorstep
when preparing the ready-wise meals all
you need is four cups of water
the water does not even need to be hot
you just pour
the food into the water you stir you
cover after about 15 minutes the meal is
ready
some meals can even be prepared directly
in the pouch which eliminates the need
for additional supplies
if you have gone through
the last year year and a half and you
still
don't understand that it's good to be
prepared for tough situations
i can't help you for the rest of us this
week my listeners can get 10
off at readywise.com when entering
knowles 10 at checkout or by calling
nine four 855-453-2945 ready wise has a
30 day no questions asked return policy
there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today that's readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com promo code
knowles 10 to get 10
off niro tandon is gone
this is a big win
in the broader scope of the biden
administration we're still going to get
a ton of radical policy but this was a
big win
this was a republican saying this is a
line we will not cross
notice here that niro tanden says look i
regret it i regret this
and i deleted a lot of these tweets
right
she deleted those tweets when she was
seeking a nomination
in the biden administration there are
two reasons to delete tweets
one because you actually regret what you
said
and two because you fear some
consequence
from what you said even though you still
believe it i rarely delete tweets
i can count on one hand i think the
number of times i've deleted tweets
and when i've deleted tweets it's
because i've actually regretted
something there's one
tweet that i actually still feel bad
about it was back during the kavanaugh
confirmation hearing
and tommy lauren the conservative
commentator was saying things that i
thought were quite wrong and i disagreed
with vehemently
and i sent out a really mean tweet about
tommy lauren
and and i felt bad about it because i
don't think that's the way people ought
to behave in public and
so i deleted that tweet i didn't delete
the tweet because i thought tommy lauren
was going to nominate me to the office
of management and budget and or
something like that and i
i it wasn't because i feared that sort
of a consequence
it's because i felt bad about it
which way do you think nero tandon was
going when she deleted those tweets do
you think it's because she actually
regretted
saying all those terrible things about
cruz and susan collins and all these
people
or do you think it's because she knew
that that was going to be very difficult
if she was insulting the people she was
relying on to confirm her to this
office and so she was trying to get
ahead of the story
notice also notice also that
republicans torpedoed her here not over
her radicalism
this woman was leading an extremely
radical organization in this country
she has espoused very radical points of
view
but it wasn't about that it was because
she attacked them personally
had nira tandon not gone personally
after
these senators i suspect she would be in
the position
already i suspect they would vote to
confirm her
so i am glad that we can play on the
vanity
of elected politicians to kick out one
of the worst nominees
but it's not going to matter much for
the more politically astute
nominees in the biden administration
they're not going to have that long
tweet record they're not going to
have personally insulted all the people
that they're trying to convince to vote
for them
so they're going to get through notice
too what what tandon said
about omb she said the office of
management budget
is a bipartisan role if i could strike
that word from the english language i
would like to do that
there is no such thing as bipartisan
partisan means that you are exclusive
you are with this party you are not with
the other party
bipartisan doesn't make any sense i
think what she means to say
is nonpartisan
so she what she wants to say is the
office of management budget look i might
be a partisan democrat but
but the omb is a non-partisan role
there there is such a thing as
nonpartisan but the whole idea of
nonpartisan depends on
where the culture stands
right because what nonpartisan means is
it's the sort of thing we can all agree
on
the sort of thing that serves the common
good and we all sort of agree on that
common good
and would niro tandon have done that
would biden have done that probably not
but
even in theory there are plenty of
things that were nonpartisan in the past
that now are partisan
a clearest example of this probably is
the american flag
the american flag was something that
both parties would wave even though
democrats were soft on communism and
they're
pretty radical starting in the 60s and
70s we would all still weigh the
american flag right
recently the american flag has become a
partisan symbol democrats now regularly
protest the american flag
they protest it on football fields they
protest it in political situations
if you see an american flag if someone
get one's got an american flag in the
back of their car
can you draw a conclusion about that
person's political party absolutely
of course you can 99 times out of 100
that's going to be a republican driving
that car
so that's a symbol used to be
nonpartisan now it is partisan
while non-partisan symbols are becoming
partisan
partisan symbols are becoming
non-partisan according to the way that
the culture is moving further and
further to the left
most egregious example of this just
happened the other day in the u.s navy
the u.s navy has released a new
mandatory training on eradicating
extremism
in this training the u.s navy claims
that black lives matter is a
non-partisan organization
the way this came out is because they
give examples of sort of questions you
might ask
about propriety in the military one
question one example question is
my boss is always talking about black
lives matter in the workspace
isn't that political stuff that they're
not supposed to be talking about at work
i'm going to stop there for a second the
obvious answer is yes it is
it not only is it political stuff it's
subversive
explicitly marxist stuff that seeks to
undo the american
nation so yeah probably they shouldn't
be talking about that in the u.s
military here's the answer the navy
gives
advocating for or against a public
policy issue as here
is authorized as long as the behavior is
otherwise
lawful and the advocacy is not
politically partisan in nature
implication being that blm is not
politically partisan
first of all organizations that seek to
dismantle
our entire american system
should not be permitted in the workplace
should not be permitted
in the government and certainly should
not be permitted in the u.s military
so that's a that's a problem in general
but even on this narrower point
blm is nonpartisan i guess that's the
case this is what the democrats have
done very successfully
they've taken contested controversial
political points of view and they've
mandated them i mean now if you say that
this example we always go back to
because it's the most ridiculous one if
you say that a man is not a woman
you are deemed not just not just a
common sense person which is what you
actually are
you're not even just deemed a partisan
you're deemed a hateful bigot who ought
to be ostracized from society
because that kind of bigoted language
has no place in america mister
if you think that men shouldn't be
allowed to go use the little girls room
we we got rid of nero tandon
uh that's that's great uh but the
radicalism is still here
this training in the navy goes on it
quote prohibits
any member of the naval services from
participating in any organization
advocating supremacist causes what is a
supremacist cause i don't i don't know
what
i think that the us navy is an american
supremacist organization right
it exists to kill our enemies that's
that seems like a supremacist clause i
think you got to get a little more
specific here when you're talking about
these words uh it prohibits any member
from participating in an organization
advocating
illegal discrimination notice the
qualifier here
not any organization advocating
discrimination
illegal discrimination illegal
discrimination would be for instance if
a college or university disadvantaged
black and hispanic applicants that would
be illegal discrimination
it would be very legal discrimination if
it if that same college or university
disadvantaged
white and asian applicants because
some racial discrimination is not only
protected by law but
mandated by law so the navy says no the
legal racial
or otherwise discrimination totally fine
probably mandatory
the illegal discrimination no thanks or
advocating the use of force or violence
against the us government or state
government has to say that
because that is still the law that's
been the law for many many decades in
this country
the radicalism though still here
jensaki our favorite white house press
secretary who is currently the white
house press secretary
people are attacking her for doing a
very bad job and she's not as talented
as her predecessors kaylee mcenany sarah
sanders i mean these were really
tough ladies who got up there knew their
stuff kaylie famously brought binders
with lots and lots of answers
and they they would give usually direct
answers to questions jen saki hasn't
been doing that
in part because maybe she's just not as
good at her job as her predecessors were
but also in part because the biden
administration's policies are so radical
they are so
unlike anything that we have seen in
this country before that if she were to
give a direct and honest answer to it
that would really put her boss in a lot
of hot water
the most recent example of this just
came yesterday
was a simple question we know joe biden
is very pro-abortion
would he go so far as to force doctors
who have
a conscious objection to abortion to
perform an abortion gensake can't answer
that question
i i love these white house press
briefings
because what you learn so much more from
the non-answers than you learn from the
answer she's not going to answer
the question directly okay try to read
between the lines listen to what she's
not saying here in this answer
first pro-life groups right now very
concerned about the
the phrase pregnancy discrimination in
the equality act you're familiar with
that i'm sure
that it would force doctors to perform
abortions even if it violates
their conscience there are also concerns
the bill would force doctors to perform
gender transition surgeries and
sterilizations again
even if it violates their conscience
what does the president president biden
say about those concerns
the president's been a long supporter of
roe v
wade it has been his consistent belief
that should be law and he will fight to
continue to protect that as being law
so this concern is that a concern of his
i think again i'm just going to state
what the president's policies are did
you have another question
will president biden keep the conscience
and religious freedom division
at hhs the office that was put in place
under president trump
will keep it in place to receive
conscience complaints from those doctors
you'll have to talk to a future
secretary becerra once he has confirmed
the smugness here the condescension
makes the
already egregious answer even worse
where he says hey
is joe biden seriously going to make
catholic doctors perform abortions or
not just catholic any doctor who opposes
killing babies in the womb she goes well
you know it's the policy
and the gobbledygoop and the dupa deputy
she could have just been up there
reading dr seuss she can't be reading dr
seuss now
of course because he's canceled but she
could have been reading the phone book
she's just
sort of stonewalling the answer and she
goes okay so that's it that's policy
um do you have any other questions he
goes yeah
all right here here's a specific law
that will prevent you from doing that is
he just not going to care about that
whatsoever
he goes well uh you're gonna have to
save that question for the secretary
but yes joe biden is going to force
doctors to butcher babies against their
own conscience
he's going to do that because and we can
be confident that he's going to do that
because he's the same guy who sued nuns
over the nun's refusal
to provide contraception and abortion
inducing drugs
mr moderate joe biden
any nominees that we can take away from
this guy any
appointees that we can shoot down works
for me
that we cannot have any confidence as
some
very misguided republicans very small
minority of republicans but some
misguided republicans said before the
election
oh biden he'll be kind of moderate don't
worry about him he's not he's he
he probably has no idea what's going on
we'll get to that a little bit later
but his administration is the most
radical administration we've ever seen
because we're living in the most radical
culture we've ever seen where
even dr seuss
is not safe from being canceled
six books by dr seuss will no longer be
published
those those books are and to think that
i saw it on mulberry street actually
these are books that i haven't really
read of dr seuss's they're kind of
smaller books though i love mulberry
street kind of wish i had that book
if i ran the zoo mcelligott's pool
on beyond zebra scrambled eggs super
and the cats quizzer these dr seuss
books probably the most beloved
children's author ever in the history of
the united states
they're banned because they have
insensitive and politically correct
depictions of cats or something i don't
i don't know i haven't haven't read them
universal
islands of adventure theme park which is
located in florida
is now looking rid of getting rid of the
dr seuss themed
area of the park in light of the new
new cancellation of certain dr seuss
books
i tried to buy these dr seuss books for
my cute little baby
sweet little newborn june wanted to make
sure that he had access to dr seuss
when he was a kid you can't find them if
you go on amazon and other places
these books the the remaining supply are
selling for like two thousand dollars
right now
because they know they're not going to
be produced anymore
the left is thrilled about this
washington post
defending the cancellation of dr seuss
this is philip
bump writing for the washington post i
don't know who philip bump is
now they don't include a biography of
him the headline if curtailing racist
imagery
in dr seuss is cancel culture what
exactly
is your culture it's a bunch of
nonsense but the lines that matter no
one is canceling dr seuss a phrase by
now so detached from reality that it
doesn't even make any sense
the author himself is dead for one thing
which is about as cancelled as a person
can get
not true if you believe in heaven you
damned heretic
but nevertheless i digress the vast vast
majority of his books
the ones without racist images or
references will still be sold the ones
without racist
imager you sure about that isn't
i'll pause there by the way that the
term racist has been expanded
in recent years expanded to mean
absolutely nothing at all
the charge that he makes about the
phrase canceled culture do you really
think
that any of our past is safe from
cancellation
i don't i think everything is going to
be called racist
or if they finally deprive the word
racist of all meaning which i think
effectively they already have
they'll just come up with a new term you
already see they posted
supremacist nationalists now is a bad
term they're just going to cancel every
do you really if you can cancel dr seuss
do you really think they're going to
stop with a few books of dr seuss
but this fellow at the washington post
goes on
if dr seuss's profile wanes a bit as a
result of the attention being paid to
his drawings the only form of
cancelling at play here to whom is harm
being done
can't be to dr seuss because he's
already dead the harm is being done of
course
to our culture but
this guy goes on seuss's caricatures are
hurtful anachronisms
anachronisms right so he's what he's
saying is it's not that they're wrong
and evil he's saying they're just
outdated he's this guy is taking a
progressive view of history
so he's actually kind of already giving
up the game he's saying they're
anachronisms
meaning things from the past are bad and
you've got to get rid of them
so he's undercutting his own argument
that other things from the past will be
fine and no they're
they're anachronistic they're from the
past the past is bad
it's a progressive view of history
whereby we have to kill
our forebears kill the culture that
we've inherited killed this great gift
that we've been given down through the
ages
to move into the future which will
liberate us what's more until a few
weeks ago my son didn't know this book
existed so where's the harm in his not
seeing its images why would anyone think
it is less problematic for a kid to be
exposed to racist caricatures of
african or at a different point in this
book asian
people than for him not to be
this isn't some toxic cancel culture if
it were what would you say
what would that say about the culture
that you're defending
so you're saying look it's not cancelled
culture he's he's
undercutting his argument immediately he
says this isn't cancelled culture
but we're going to cancel all that bad
old culture and what are you going to
defend it what are you a racist or
something
right this this isn't cancelled culture
but if it were
are you a racist you're sure not going
to defend it are you
there is no limiting principle here this
is another
aspect of our culture and political
correctness specifically that trump got
100 right and everybody made fun of him
at the time you remember when
when he was defending robert e lee
statues there's a big left-wing hubbub
to take down robert e lee
who is one of the noblest men
to ever fight for a bad cause right
robert e lee
the idea that robert e lee was some kind
of vicious man
is preposterous it's anti-historical
and the idea that we need to erase half
of our country or more than half of our
country that probably
i don't think the left just wants to
erase the south i think they want to
erase the entire
traditional american nation it's crazy
so he said okay you're
you're going after robert e lee now and
some people aren't going to defend him
because he fought for the mean old
southerners
you really think they're going to stop
with robert e lee no i think they're
going to go after
lincoln they're going to go after
jefferson they're going to go after
washington and people laughed at him and
they mocked him at the time and then
what happened within
a year or two left-wing agitators
started pulling down statues of
jefferson and washington and lincoln
renaming schools erasing
our culture
i don't even care that much about dr
seuss i mean i liked the cat in the hat
and a few of the dr seuss books i
enjoyed them when i was a kid i intend
to read them to my kids he
he was a very talented children's book
author
even though he was a liberal democrat by
the way that's fine it's okay i can have
my disagreements with the children's
book author
the person who suffers when you cancel
these guys
it's not dr seuss he's enjoying his
eternal reward either up above or down
below not for me to know
the people who suffer are us because the
books are good
and they're they are nice for children
and they
show us something they're artistic they
are they delight little children as they
have for decades
and what people like this humorless nut
in the washington post
and the left-wingers who want to get rid
of soos because of
racism whatever that means these days
what they are doing is taking away that
delight specifically from children
they're actually it's like
they the next they're going to be taking
candy away from children
and they're defending it based on their
preposterous theories but there is no
limiting principle we're all going to
lose it
all that lovely art all those wonderful
things about our culture that we cherish
it's gone by the principles that they
are advocating ben
is going to be speaking about this dr
seuss issue in
on his show today talking about the
modern day book burning which is digital
and i guess the publisher is actually
just not putting out dr seuss also
you have to check out ben in the daily
wires newest series debunked every
friday ben is exposing popular fallacies
that left-wing activists and politicians
put forward in his first episode
which is now available to daily wire
members ben
is going to debunk the arguments of the
minimum wage
debunked is available exclusively to
daily wire members go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership head on over to
daily wire we'll be right back with a
lot more
dr seuss is being canceled this is an
example of a bad cancellation
but you know i have said many times on
this show i think
cancel culture is not the most helpful
phrase because
in the words of william f buckley jr i'm
an epistemological optimist it's a very
tedious phrase which means that i don't
think the culture should be totally open
i think it should be closed to certain
ideas i think it should be
ordered toward good things and it should
discourage
bad things so they're bad cancellations
like dr seuss
but there are good cancellations like
the one that's going on right now to
andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo i think is being canceled
for politically convenient and largely
contrived reasons
he's they conveniently have discovered
sex scandals that all seem very vague
and in some cases
the people who are being implicated them
are explicitly saying i did not feel
that this was sexual harassment
but really that's just an excuse to
cancel him because
he threw thousands of elderly new
yorkers into dangerous places with the
coronavirus
then he knew about it then he covered it
up now he's under a federal probe
bill de blasio a radical democrat in new
york
is taking the opportunity to pile on to
andrew cuomo and hopefully end his
political career
first of all it sickened me it sickened
me um
the thought of a powerful man trying to
take advantage of his power
intimidate a young woman um
you know and just the sense of like he
was treating her like
you know again these are allegations and
we need a full investigation but if that
was
what truly happened it was like he was
treating her like she was his property
just disgusting creepy and um
you know i had seen so many situations
where he was abusive to people
in a profound way not just raising your
voice but profoundly abusive a lot of
folks
use the word torture with him that he's
you've seen this you've seen this
personally mayor
i've seen him not in the sense of sexual
harassment i've seen him be
abusive in a way that would not be
accepted by anyone else in leadership
so more vague allegations he goes yeah
yeah he's been abusive and the radio
host
says to the bolshevik mayor of new york
city
he says hold on you've seen this
specific behavior that we're talking
about it goes well you know yeah it's
just abusive
it's bad it's bad behavior and so he's
got to go
i don't i don't particularly have a dog
in this fight to me cuomo versus de
blasio is like the mensheviks
versus the bolsheviks new york is so
far gone at this point that i'm i'm not
interested i will say
cuomo if you've got to pick between
arsenic and cyanide
cuomo is a far more preferable choice to
de blasio
cuomo is a kind of old-school machine
democrat
whereas de blasio is an actual
true believing radical a real really
radical far far
leftist so they're all going after cuomo
now uh
fine by me i don't mind if andrew
cuomo's political career goes down
i do though think that we should be a
little more
honest about it with ourselves and not
give in to this idea that because
somebody makes an allegation that cuomo
handed a reporter an italian sausage at
a fair
several years ago that that constitutes
rape or something i just think
i think those kind of the me too
arguments against andrew cuomo
seem to me a little vague right now i
haven't seen a lot of evidence for it
the real crime is what he did on
coronavirus and we should not let him
forget it
i'm a little worried that the more we
talk about the so-called sex scandal
the less we're talking about the actual
scandal
which is his abuse of power in the
cover-up of his covid policies
and the policies themselves which were
extraordinarily
deadly another guy getting canceled
right now another politician
nicolas sarkozy the former president of
france nicolas sarkozy was a more
conservative president
after uh years and centuries i guess of
left-wing governance there
sarkozy was found guilty of corruption
and influence peddling on monday
he was sentenced to three years in
prison he probably isn't going to serve
that he'll probably you know
some will be taken off and then he'll
probably get house arrest
but still he'll be he'll be sentenced to
that he was found guilty of trying to
bribe a magistrate in exchange for
information about a legal case in which
he was implicated according to the
associated press
this is kind of typical political stuff
it doesn't seem like
anything sarkozy did was was
particularly extraordinary
i'm going to take an unpopular position
in these populist days
and say i think it's bad when
politicians
are sent to prison after their time in
office
at least at the national level i mean
there are some local more local guys who
are crooks and they
they need to pay for it but i think it's
bad for the country
when leaders of the country go to prison
i
recognize that conservatives had a good
time chanting law corrupt lock her up
but i don't think anyone seriously
thought that hillary clinton
was going to go to prison when trump
made that line in the debate he says
yeah you don't want me to be president
because you'd be in jail you know it's a
good line
but everyone's laughing about it because
no one's no one's really taking it
seriously
i think the left now probably does want
to throw trump in an orange jumpsuit
but we'll see if that actually happens
biden has backed off of that as well
it's just ugly it's it's banana republic
stuff
and i'm not saying that politicians at
the highest level
sometimes don't deserve criminal
punishment or to go to prison or
something they do
i'm just saying that it is worth it for
the people
to give them a little more leniency
because
it reflects so badly on us it reflects
so badly on the people themselves it
really
degrades the government i think biden is
awful i think he is one of the most
notorious
liars in american politics i think he is
pushing radical policies
that threaten to undo the entire country
i don't think we should throw him in the
clink one because he wouldn't know where
he was i guess that would maybe make his
prison sentence a little easier he'd
just wake up in the morning and say oh
wow
read redecorate it here huh okay well i
just go back to eating his porridge or
whatever
but i i do think it would be bad
if we were to throw these guys in prison
it would just it would so destabilize
our political system more so perhaps
than it already is
but it would be elder abuse too joe
biden
joe biden is doing worse
and worse each day it's not like the
campaign was a big stress on him now
he's president he's
evening out he's he's forgetting what
he's saying he
he's not holding a lot of public
appearances and a recent one
explains why he he can't even remember
the names of people that he's reading
off a list you all being very polite
you're with me all day
and it's dinner time
good afternoon or almost actually this
evening
and i want to thank you uh governor
miss abbott for uh your hospitality and
your friendship
and uh representing senator cornyn
i think he had to go back uh i think he
was getting on a plane he told me a
little last he came in to see me last
event
and representatives uh
cheryl shirley jackson lee al green
sylvia garcia lizzie pinelli
excuse me pinell and uh what am i doing
here
i'm going to lose track here what am i
doing here we're losing track here maybe
he should have given the
press conference at breakfast rather
than in the evening he's saying here
it's dinner time
and sometimes people do a little better
in the morning as they get older than
they do at night that's clearly what's
happening here
not even just that he forgets the names
not even just that he's so slow and
halting he's slurring his words
and i'm sure the democrats are going to
blame this on the the
childhood stutter that disappeared
magically for 65 years of joe biden's
political career but then
magically came back again when the 78
year old ran for president
but it's not not a stutter it's not
ordinary politics he's slurring his word
he sounds like a guy at a bar
after several drinks that sort of thing
happens when you get a little bit up
there in age but
this is not good stuff for the
commander-in-chief and
what it means is we're in a position
that the the younger more able people in
the administration are probably running
things
joe biden paid a visit to the southern
border which he can't wait to
reopen he can't wait to pull those the
little bit of wall that did go up he's
going to pull it down probably himself
he and cornpop are going to team up and
rip the wall down joe biden was asked by
reporters hey
mr biden what what did you learn when
you went down to the wall his
answer pretty vague
did you receive a briefing about the
border today
yes i did what did you learn a lot
is there
oh gosh it's even worse that's right
it's not it's not even that he went down
to the border it's he just received the
briefing right so he should have the
bullet points
he should know okay i learned this this
this this you got a briefing on the
border
yeah uh-huh what time is it can i get
out of here
yeah you got what did you learn about
the briefing a lot
see ya goodbye i mean that's a joke if
you were to
have a sitcom about the white house that
would be an answer
that is not a fair answer if you were
the actual
president and i say all of this not to
make fun of joe biden because i actually
do think it's sort of elder abuse he's
fair game because he
chose to run for office and he's
inflicting a lot of damage on our
country and
if you're going to be in politics you
have to be able to take the punches of
politics
but i i point all of this out because
no matter how much he slurs his words
the guy is going to be effective
he's he's going to be more effective
than trump
pains me to say that and it's not even a
personal
attack on donald trump i think trump did
the best he could
but donald trump was fighting against
the entire
bureaucracy the entire media
many elected politicians and many people
in his own party
and many much more experienced career
politicians
so he was at a great disadvantage joe
biden has all of those institutions
working for him
and joe biden has spent his entire life
wielding power in washington one thing
that he's going to do is very simple
he is trying to root out all the
bureaucrats that were installed by trump
there actually weren't too many of them
but he was this this was uh
the way this is being reported in the
news joe biden is reportedly attempting
to sniff out federal bureaucrats and
stalled by and loyal to his predecessor
to purge the federal government of trump
supporters as well he should
as well he should if i were president
first thing i would do would be to try
to root out
all of the partisans who pretend to be
nonpartisans but they're partisans
working in the bureaucracy who could
undermine my agenda this was one of the
biggest challenges trump faced
and he never quite figured out how to
overcome it maybe just because the
problem can't be overcome
which is that trump gets elected he's
theoretically running the government but
he's not really running the government
because the government is run by the
executive agencies and the bureaucracy
which is going to be there
long after trump is gone and it's very
hard
to get rid of those employees he got rid
of a lot of them
but so many more remain i think of this
example
of just the department of homeland
security the department of homeland
security which is a very new agency and
it's just one agency among many in the
in
washington has over 200 000 employees
it's closer to a quarter million
employees it's just one agency
think about how big that is so what
biden is going to do is go in there and
try to pick out all
of the trump people
because people are power in an
administrative bureaucracy
and that's going to have long long
lasting effects speaking of
administrative agencies
i i don't want this story to go down the
memory hole
the left is is going to try to do that
and they're already trying to do that
when democrats impeach donald trump what
did they imp
the second time i'm sorry that i have to
clarify what did they impeach him for
they impeached him for inciting a riot
an insurrection at the capitol on
january 6th
that charge was always bogus they didn't
have evidence for it but what was the
key piece of evidence they presented not
to make a logical argument but to tug on
the
emotional heart strings the key piece of
evidence was
that an officer died because of the
violent
mob insurrection officer brian sicknick
was killed and they he they threw a fire
extinguisher in his head then it turned
out that wasn't true even though it was
reported in the new york times turned
out
wasn't true at all then there were
questions about officer sicknick's death
then his family said stop politicizing
his death then it came out that officer
siknik seemed to have been a trump
supporter
and then the story just kind of went
away
well fbi director christopher wray
has investigated officer sicknick's very
tragic death
they he says that they can't confirm a
cause of death
there have been some reports that he
died of a stroke or some pre-existing
health condition
this was the basis of the impeachment
trial
we've now had an investigation what over
two months now
almost and they can't confirm
a cause of death other other people who
died that day
were not killed it seems by the violent
mob maybe in one case
but it's still sort of uncertain the
only death that's very clear is the
death of the trump supporter ashley
babbitt
what about the pipe bombs remember there
were pipe bombs planted
outside the rnc and the dnc i think
maybe outside the capital too
very cl we still don't know who planted
the pipe bombs dc is the most surveilled
state city rather in in the entire
country
what about that when are we going to get
answers on these sorts of things
seems like we're never going to get
answers on these sorts of things that we
should we should be able to get clear
answers on
and more specifically answers on things
that are being used
as the primary propaganda
for the left to push their agenda to
continue to keep
washington dc practically under martial
rule it looks like it's a city
in under occupation in the middle east
or something like that more than it does
like an american city
we're not getting answers to that is
that incompetence or is that a power
grab
seems seems to me i mean i i don't doubt
the incompetence of the
administrative agencies but
this seems to me rotten and the
mainstream media
just don't want to cover it time to get
past this insanity time
to open back up our country
cynical politicians are using
fears over the coronavirus lockdowns
fears over
insurrection fears over this fears over
that
to take away our rights to take away our
traditions
to take away the american way of life
and it's just gone on and on and on and
on
two weeks to slow the spread 15 days to
slow the spread we are now coming up
this month we will be coming up on one
year there is no excuse anymore as far
as i'm concerned
anybody who still supports locking down
the country
ought to be removed from office
possibly tarred and feathered and
certainly run out of the country on a
rail
i'm sick of it i don't want to hear it
anymore any republican
any republican who says maybe we should
still sort of lock down i want them
expelled from the republican party we
obviously we have no say over democrats
democrats are using these methods
but certainly republicans don't need to
help them well finally finally finally
some states are opening back up now some
states like florida already doing an
excellent job ron desantis absolutely
killing it down there
finally texas which i think should have
opened up a long time ago
is reopening to 100 capacity
the governor there finally decided to do
it we turn now
to uh senator cruz for reaction freedom
my man absolutely right freedom i love
it that clip
was from cpac and it's funny some on the
left were kind of making fun of the clip
of
senator cruz who just he was giving this
sort of broader articulate speech and
then he said freedom
i love it yeah good i want all of our
politicians freedom
i want them to be screaming at morning
noon and night until these cynical
and sociopathic politicians reopen our
country good news
finally better late than never governor
abbott wish that this had happened
sooner
but better late than never i'm not even
going to criticize abbott for not doing
this sooner
because i don't see any reason
to have any sort of infighting on this
kind of
an essential matter for a country just
reopen the damn country
mississippi doing this too mississippi
going even further
mississippi was always kind of dealing
with the virus in a sort of
more reasonable way than some of the
crazier states but the mississippi
governor is saying no more mass mandates
starting tomorrow we are lifting all of
our county mass mandates and businesses
will be able to operate at full capacity
without any state imposed rules
our hospitalizations and case numbers
have plummeted and the vaccine is being
rapidly distributed it is time
my man governor tate reads terrific
so glad to hear that i also don't want
to hear from republicans anymore who
tell us to wear the masks
i i have to wear the mask
in very limited circumstances because we
live
in a extremely corrupt regime but that's
the way it is
and the limited circumstance i guess
would be the airplanes that's the one
where you you really can't do it
and so there might be cases where i
think okay do i need to go on this trip
if i don't need to then i'm not going to
go on the flight because i don't want to
wear the stupid mask
but if there are some cases where i
think okay i should go on this trip
i can use this trip to fight against the
scrub system
i'll make a political calculation to
wear the mask otherwise
i am not going to wear a mask any more
than i
have to and the way that we can reduce
the number of
situations in which we have to is for
republicans to grow a spine i know that
will be very difficult
for many republicans and to stop
defending the masks which are the symbol
and an enforcement instrument of this
outrageous power grab
that some of us knew a year ago was not
going to only last two weeks
but now i think we should all know as we
come up on the one year anniversary
get rid of it this stuff is creepy
and it is insane clearest
portrayal of this from the la unified
schools la unified schools
has a video out to promote their new
policies for how they're going to reopen
after covid now we know from the science
capital s trademark over the e we know
from the science
that there is no medical reason for the
schools to remain closed
the kids don't really transmit it very
much the teachers and
faculty are not at any particularly high
risk of getting the virus
the reason that the schools are
remaining closed is because corrupt
left-wing teacher unions are too lazy
and they want to get a paycheck for
doing nothing so
la schools now are pushing how are we
going to reopen in this
tell me this isn't the creepiest thing
you've ever heard there's never been
anything like this virus in our lifetime
often it's hard to see the effects it's
having on our children
has this conversation taken place in
your home
mom i'm scared about going back to
school i don't want to get sick
and i don't want to get you and dad sick
our scientists tell us there are three
things we must do to stay
safe wear masks make sure we social
distance
and wash our hands and now your school
with the help of microsoft corporation
has created another
introducing daily pass your exclusive
ticket for safely going back to school
each week you can schedule your free
on-campus covent test
the results are displayed in your daily
pass and if you choose to take your test
off campus
you can post the results in your daily
pass and the moment vaccinations are
available
you'll simply be able to schedule yours
through your daily pass
but the real magic is your daily health
check just answer a few simple health
questions every day
and like magic your entrance ticket
appears
it's so wonderful just give us access to
all of your medical data
and i don't know send us some of your
blood too and then
then we can all go back to school and
give us all your rights and
don't have any privacy anymore does this
ever happen in your home
hey mom i'm really afraid of coronavirus
and i i'm so afraid of going to school
no that doesn't happen because kids
don't feel that way because kids are at
practically zero risk of this virus and
they all want to go back to school
and their rates of depression anxiety
suicide among
kids has been going up because of these
psycho politicians
and the technocrat in tyrants and lab
coats like dr fauci
who are screwing up their lives over
nothing but a power grab that's what's
going on
not that creepy video it gets somehow
somehow it's even
creepier by the end so how did it go
dad i have to admit i was scared at
first but then i felt
so safe it was so good to be back
thanks for keeping me safe i love you so
much
[Music]
what if you're gonna push this kind of
creepy propaganda
can't you it i don't know get better
dialogue dialogue that doesn't send a
chill up our spine thank you
bill gates i mean daddy thank you dr
fauci oh daddy daddy keep meaning to say
daddy
can i call him daddy fauci daddy daddy
dr fauci
uh no this does not represent the
situation
that we find ourselves in and it doesn't
represent the situation we want that's
the kind of radicalism that is being
pushed not by the fringes that's being
pushed
by the liberal establishment we need to
head them off and stop them every chance
we get if it's by
shooting down a nominee to some office
in the government
if it's through elections if it's
through civil disobedience on our own
in prudent cases such as
going back living our lives seeing our
families taking off that dumb mask
makes sense to me i'm michael knows this
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
freedom
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show